Prof: Good morning.
We'll get started.
As you know,
this isn't--there isn't going
to be a lecture this morning at
all.
We're going instead to have a
review session,
in which I'll be very much
dependent on your having
questions, and our having a
joint discussion.
So, what I'm expecting to be
able to do is to,
when you have questions,
or want to contribute to--
I've got some questions as
well--we can put our heads
together.
And there'll be a microphone,
I hope, that we can pass
around, and everyone will be
audible.
The first thing I should say is
just to talk,
just for a minute,
about the exam itself;
because I've now written it.
So, at least we can say on that
much I'm the world's authority.
The exam will look like this.
There will be two parts.
The first part will be the ID
section,
and that will have--let's see,
you've got the list of
identifications,
and I've literally just chosen
ten of them,
and that will constitute two
points each,
or a total of twenty points for
the ID section.
And, so, you can work out how
to budget your time,
in that regard.
Clearly, you're not meant to
write an essay;
just even bullet points or a
short paragraph is all that's
expected with regard to the
identifications.
The second part of the exam
consists of three essays,
and I'm--that is,
three on a list of three--and
I'll ask you to write on two of
them.
And each of the essays
therefore will count forty
points.
So, part two of the exam will
count eighty points altogether.
That tells how you should
budget your time.
The essay questions are much
more important than the
identifications.
That's really the structure of
the exam.
I can't think really of
anything else that I can say
about that.
But let me see if
anyone--before we turn to
substantive issues,
does anyone have any questions
about the format of the exam or
what's likely to be on it?
I can repeat what I've said
before.
The exam period itself is
notionally three hours,
though you also get an
additional half-hour as a grace
period.
That, I understand,
is the Yale system,
and we'll adhere to that.
The exam will also--I wanted to
stress this--
it will cover the whole of the
course,
from the beginning,
and it won't simply be on the
last part of the course,
since the mid-term.
It will cover everything that
we've dealt with since January
down to today.
So, are there any questions
before we turn to the substance,
about the format of the exam,
or what you could expect or not
expect,
or anything of that nature?
Yes?
Student:  Do we need to
bring in any sort of readings on
the ID section?
Prof: The question was,
do you need to bring in
readings on the ID section?
I think that depends entirely
on which ID you deal with.
Some of the IDs are directly
based on the reading that you've
done.
So, for example,
if I ask Daniel Defoe,
to identify,
it would be really odd if you
didn't bring in the Journal
of the Plague Year,
and why it was important.
Okay?
But if I asked you about,
say, the Paris School of
Medicine, that you didn't
actually have readings on,
then it wouldn't be
necessarily.
So, it really depends on the
nature of the particular ID in
question.
Okay?
Anything else about the exam?
Okay, thanks.
Then let's move on to the
substantive part of the review,
and the issues that we've been
dealing with in the course.
And I thought one way we might
start would be for me to ask you
a question;
which is what do you think I
should sensibly ask you about on
the final?
What would make good final exam
questions for you,
based on the material that
you've covered?
And then we could put our heads
together a little bit to think
about what might be some
elements of the answers that
you'd provide in them.
Does anyone have a question
that I ought to ask you?
It's never too late;
I could change the questions I
wrote yesterday.
You think I should ask you
nothing?
It's always a possibility, too.
Okay, well I've got some
thoughts, if you like,
for things that we might want
to deal with.
One was this-- and I'm going to
ask and see if any of you would
like to help me think through
this particular issue--
if we're dealing with the
impact of major epidemic
diseases on society,
what would be--is it true to
think that it's really the
overall mortality that provides
the major way in which we can
assess whether this was an
important event or it wasn't?
Is that how we judge the
significance of the passage of
an epidemic disease through
society?
Do we--is the body count,
in other words,
the most important factor?
Or is it something else?
How do we--what factors
determine whether an epidemic
disease really is a significant
historical event or it isn't?
Do you have any thoughts on
that particular issue?
Yes--please? Thank you.
Student:  Morbidity.
**
Prof: Okay,
thanks very much.
Did everyone hear?
The candidate for an answer
would be that it's not just the
mortality,
but we need to look at the
morbidity,
and even more than that we need
to look at the class,
or the profile of the victims
of the epidemic,
and that it makes a big
difference whether the victims
of the disease are the elderly,
and perhaps infants;
in other words,
whether it seems like a normal
event in the life of that
society, or whether it targets
instead a different patient
population.
If it targets people in the
prime of life,
it's experienced in a very
different way.
So, clearly the class profile
is important,
and not just the mortality,
or even the morbidity.
Are there other factors?
Yes?
Student:  One argument
in favor of mortality mattering
is it didn't really have much of
an impact on things like
society,
and it didn't prove lasting.
Like you could control things.
So you'd have like a really big
morbidity but a small mortality,
and so that prevented a panic.
Prof: That's great.
**
Prof: Maybe you could
start again.
I don't think everyone could
hear you.
Student:  One argument
in favor of mortality mattering
is that flu,
which didn't really have that
much of a lasting impact on
society,
had a really high morbidity but
a really small mortality,
and everyone knew that,
and so they weren't panicked
when it came.
Prof: Okay.
There's the idea then that we
shouldn't retreat too much from
mortality, that it really does
matter.
And I'm really happy that you
did something very important,
which was not just to leave
this matter hanging in the
abstract,
but to tack it to a particular
example.
And, so, it's really important
that you bring in particular
diseases to clinch your
argument.
Talking about influenza is
exactly the way that the
argument ought to go,
and weighing that versus other
diseases that were different.
That's good.
Thank you.
Right, someone else?
Oh, there we go.
Student:  At the same
time, I think that what that
really speaks to is more the
reaction of society to
something.
So, that it's important to say
that it's not just a number that
matters;
that mortality rate isn't so
much the important part as much
as how people were able to kind
of incorporate that into their
lives.
Because as you were saying,
flu wasn't necessarily the most
striking example to people.
However, I think that
certain--even times like
tuberculosis,
where you have people who are
dying but in very much longer
periods.
So, you have more time for
reactions in literature and art,
and those have just as much of
an impact.
And, in fact,
they're really lasting impacts
because we still have those
pieces of epidemic art and
literature to look back on,
to see how they had impacts on
society.
Prof: Okay,
yes, thanks very much.
So, it's--you want to
complicate the matter even
more--
it really depends on how it's
perceived,
perceptions-- and also that's
reflected in the arts and in
literature,
and you're giving the example
of tuberculosis and the time
period and how lasting the
impact is.
That tuberculosis has--one of
its reasons for having such an
impact was that it was such a
slow event,
and was with society for so
long, and people reflected on
that,
and it impacted the arts and
culture.
Absolutely, I think that would
be.
So, we've got now--in order to
deal with this,
we've dealt with influenza and
tuberculosis as contrasting
factors,
two diseases,
in very different ways.
And it's certainly true that
also on the exam we will be
dealing--
I'll be asking you to be
comparative in your discussion
of diseases,
and to bring in more than one
disease in order to deal with
major questions that cut across
the whole of our course.
Okay, thanks.
Anything else we ought to put
in to our answer to this
question?
Would it be good to deal with
just two diseases in dealing
with that?
Would this be--would you get an
A for bringing in influenza and
tuberculosis?
What other diseases might be
important in considering this
question?
Yes, thanks.
**
Student:  You might
consider cholera,
because it was sort of the
opposite of tuberculosis,
in that it had a very rapid
onset, and so the specifics
surrounding the disease itself
had an effect on how it was
perceived as something
frightening,
and something gross.
Prof: Okay.
So, you would throw cholera
into the mix.
And I think the reason
you're--if I've understood you,
you're saying that this should
take us into another whole
realm,
which is to deal with the
symptoms,
because there was something
particularly frightening and
disgusting about Asiatic
cholera,
and that conditioned its impact.
People were really terrified by
its arrival, because of the
nature of its symptomatology.
That's another dimension that
we ought to consider.
It's not just morbidity,
not just mortality,
not just the profile of the
victims, but the kind of
suffering that the disease
imposes on its victims.
So, the symptomatology is
tremendously important.
Okay, anything else on that
question?
Our grade is going up all the
time.
Several examples,
specific cases,
that's comparison,
that's all extremely important.
Anything else anyone wants to
throw in on this question?
So, collectively we've got what?
An A on this?
Okay, we'll pat ourselves on
the back, and let's move on and
see if there are other issues we
might like to discuss.
What is it--let me see,
I'm wondering--
I mentioned something in
passing, and threw out a phrase,
which was that we might want to
consider some diseases in our
course "diseases of
modernity."
I'm wondering if that's
actually a useful concept.
It may be that I misspoke.
Or is modernity in some senses
a factor that promotes our
vulnerability to high-impact
epidemic diseases;
or at least certain ones among
them?
Is that true or is that wrong?
Great.
Student:  always like to
put a finer edge on it
**
Prof: You really do, yes.
Student: I might put a
finer edge on it for the class
by asking them if any real
progress in social or medical
response to epidemic disease has
occurred over the time span of
the course?
Prof: Okay.
In other words,
are we more vulnerable now,
or much less vulnerable,
as a result of public health
policies and understanding of
infectious diseases,
since, let's see,
poor Daniel Defoe lived through
the bubonic plague.
That's sort of your question,
right?
Student:  Precisely.
Student:  It struck me
that your definition of a
disease of modernity refers to
structural factors.
Right?
So, for instance,
the role of mass transit
technologies,
perhaps urbanization in
abetting the spread of disease.
Isn't that the sense of disease
of modernity?
Prof: I think you're
right.
Who knows what I meant when I
said it.
But it would seem to me,
if we were retrospectively to
try to make sense of a phrase
like that, we--and this is
important and all.
Here's a general point for any
answers that you give in an
exam.
You would have to provide a
definition of what it actually
means.
Modernity is a lovely phrase,
but it doesn't really--
its meaning is not
self-evident,
and it was only--
your grade would rise very
significantly if you weren't
just to talk about modernity,
but you were actually to do
what you just did,
but to say, "What does
that mean?"
and point to factors such as
urbanization,
mass transit,
population growth,
things like that,
that give it a meaning;
and possibly also the
development of an understanding
scientifically of the biology
and the medicine of the
diseases,
and therefore public health
policies and practices.
That, I think,
would be a much better way to
approach this idea of whether
it's a disease of modernity or
not.
And I'm just wondering what
would you say?
Are we less vulnerable now than
London was at the time of Defoe;
or is it still the same;
or are we vulnerable,
but vulnerable to different
kinds of diseases,
at least here in the West?
Okay, great.
**
Student:  I would say
that we're more vulnerable to
the spread of disease and to
diseases that are a result of
over-sanitation,
but that we're also more
capable of dealing with them,
scientifically and
technologically.
Prof: Okay.
So, it's neither--you're
rejecting that opposition of
being more or less vulnerable.
We're more vulnerable in
certain ways,
and less vulnerable in others.
Perhaps we're not as
susceptible to certain diseases
in the same way,
but we're susceptible to other
diseases in different ways.
Maybe the mode of transmission
is an important factor.
But you wanted to say something
too.
Let's come to you.
**
Student:  I also think
that in a way though we're sort
of like shifting from one vague
misconception of disease
causality to another.
Because the earliest modes of
disease prevention were
quarantine and just,
like, whatever they could--like
sanitation, like with Chadwick.
But then we moved to this magic
bullet thing,
once we figured out that it was
the germ theory.
And for a really long time--and
I think it still sort of
persists--is this idea that we
can cure something just by
finding a magic drug.
And that isn't really how it
works, and there are a lot of
other factors.
And even though we sort of
acknowledge that sometimes,
I don't think that it's
necessarily permeated our
efforts to cure a lot of
different diseases.
Like with AIDS you can kind of
see that there's efforts at
education and things like that.
But as long as there's poverty,
there's going to be diseases
that disproportionately affect
the poor,
and I don't think that we're
anywhere near solving that
problem.
Prof: Okay.
So, as I understand it,
you're saying that we have made
advances in understanding,
and there are diseases for
which there are public health
measures that are effective,
and there are sometimes magic
bullets.
But we have become rather
over--we overemphasize the
importance of treatments,
and we underestimate the social
economic determinants of
disease.
And, so, diseases thrive on
certain social and economic
conditions--
and you mentioned poverty,
for example--
and so until those underlying
substrates of epidemic diseases
are dealt with,
we'll always remain vulnerable.
So, that would suggest--maybe
we should take that on for a
second.
Is that a valid conclusion from
the course,
from your readings and all the
rest,
that diseases,
all diseases,
are diseases of poverty?--
would seem to be something you
were maybe suggesting.
Or even if you weren't,
I'm suggesting it on your
behalf.
Is that a valid conclusion to
draw;
that really the essential
driver of epidemic disasters is
poverty?
All diseases are diseases of
poverty;
is that right?
Right.
Great, thanks.
Student:  I would
disagree with that statement
because although--
Prof: Okay.
I would too.
Student:  We see that,
in some cases,
notably cholera,
it did only strike the poor,
and the rich were pretty much
unaffected by the disease,
in terms of health, health-wise.
There's been plenty of other
diseases that really haven't
shown any liking to any specific
socioeconomic class.
The flu just came in and,
since it was so easily spread
from person to person,
even if you were walking into a
store run by someone of a lower
class,
you could easily get that from
them.
So, I think most diseases,
even though some did strike the
poor to a greater extent,
you can't classify them solely
as being diseases of poverty.
Where poverty might have--not
embellished--but poverty might
have--imight have made it worse.
Someone in poverty would
probably be worse off due to
influenza than a richer person.
But I don't think it caused
most of the diseases we've
talked about.
Prof: Okay.
There is the theory,
then, that it really depends on
which disease,
and that it's a gross
oversimplification to say that
poverty is the cause of epidemic
disease.
It exacerbates the situation,
probably for all.
But there are clearly certain
diseases that are driven by
other factors--
and influenza was a case in
point--there's certain diseases
that really do seem to be
equal-opportunity afflictions,
in that they seem to strike all
rungs of society,
rather than just certain
economic and social classes.
And influenza was a
good--respiratory diseases
perhaps veer towards that pole.
But then I think you're saying
that in any case it's probably
not fair also completely to
eliminate poverty;
that it's a sort of spectrum,
and some diseases are more
responsive to poverty,
and others less.
But that even
influenza---perhaps if you're
poor, you don't have access to
medical care,
to nursing, and to medications,
and so on.
And, so, it's more of a
problem, but it's a universal
problem nonetheless.
Have I understood you right,
correctly?
Okay.
Good, thank you.
I think you'd be right.
And I think it would be good if
in the answer--
let's say we give a more
coherent answer if we gave a
range of diseases in dealing
with the answer,
some at one end of the spectrum
and others at the other.
Right?
So, influenza would be great.
But it would be a mistake just
to put influenza into the
answer.
We'd want to give contrasting
examples.
The answer, then,
as many historical answers,
has to be qualified and
nuanced, and just to say all
diseases are diseases of poverty
is probably quite wrong.
Okay.
There was another--you were
going to--
Student:  Well I was
just going to ask if we could
maybe take the diseases that we
looked at and almost rank them
in the order of how they
affect--
like how much certain diseases
** from flu to
cholera.
Prof: Okay.
Well, why don't I be a really,
really nasty person and ask if
you could help me out?
How would you rank them?
Student:  I haven't got
a clue.
**.
Prof: You've got lots of
people to help you out.
You're not on your own.
Okay?
Student:
**.
Prof: No.
Student:  I would start
with flu and then I'd get to
cholera.
Prof: Okay.
So, one end of the spectrum,
we put influenza;
and that would clearly be the
least responsive to poverty as a
driver.
The other end of the spectrum
you'd put Asiatic cholera,
which is clearly very sensitive
to social and economic factors,
to living conditions,
to dirt and filth,
to lack of light,
to overcrowding.
I hope you would then--you see,
in your essay poverty too
needs--it is not self-evident
what it means.
Why is poverty a factor?
And I hope you would talk about
filth, access to medical care,
education, overcrowding,
bad housing,
sewage.
Those are the things that
cholera thrives on.
So, you would be right that
way, putting influenza and
cholera at opposite poles of the
spectrum.
But once again,
we have to remember that this
is not absolute,
because wealthy people also
succumbed to Asiatic cholera,
just in much smaller numbers.
Okay.
Right, thanks.
Student:  I think I
would put malaria,
and to a lesser extent than
plague, on the cholera side of
things.
Malaria, because they--it was a
big working condition disease,
and a lot of people who were in
the lower classes worked in the
rice fields where--
and worked and lived in areas
that they couldn't have the
simple protection against
mosquitoes.
And I said plague to a lesser
extent on the cholera side
because,
as we saw in Journal of the
Plague Year,
a lot of the richer people were
able to leave London and use
financial means to get away from
the disease.
And even though it spread,
the poorer people couldn't do
that and they had to stay.
Prof: Okay.
So, we have a couple of other
examples of diseases that might
be along the level of
poverty--being driven by
poverty.
And malaria was an example
because of the particularly
laboring and living conditions.
It's partly an occupational
disease, and so it strikes
peasants and people who work in
conditions that make them
vulnerable;
and it's a house disease that
depends on overcrowding and
living in housing that's porous
to flying insects.
Poverty clearly is important to
the spread of malaria.
We've seen, to some extent,
that plague has some--
it could be argued either way,
but you're absolutely right to
introduce plague as something--
a case to be argued as to
whether it is or isn't.
I'm wondering what about some
other diseases transmitted
differently?
One factor might be--then you
might say it might depend partly
on means of transmission of the
disease;
perhaps airborne disease is
less driven by poverty.
Ones that travel by the
oral-fecal route,
or by vectors,
might be important.
What about sexually transmitted
disease;
and is syphilis a disease of
poverty?
You wanted to--
Student:  I would put
AIDS and syphilis towards the
flu end of things.
Although by modern maps of
where these diseases are highly
prevalent, it would seem
otherwise.
But I think that there is
actually a sort of not
poverty-based reason for that.
Prof: Okay.
So, we have a candidate then
for--two other candidates to go
at the influenza end of the
spectrum: syphilis and AIDS.
I'm wondering if everyone would
agree with that.
Yes, please?
Oh sorry.
Go ahead first.
Student:  Yes,
I would put AIDS more towards
the middle of the spectrum,
because AIDS did have a
predilection for marginalized
groups.
But at the same time it could
affect anyone,
including a heterosexual man
from a wealthy family.
So, I think it sort of goes in
the middle.
If I could add one to the list,
maybe I would put SARS as
closer to the flu end of the
spectrum,
because it did seem to--and
this adds to the idea that
airborne diseases are less
driven by poverty--
because it did seem to affect
everyone.
But at the same time,
it did hit areas that had a
strong health infrastructure,
and that helped to quell the
disease somewhat.
Prof: Okay.
I'm wondering--I like your
answer and I'm just wondering if
with HIV/AIDS we would want even
to make distinctions,
in that HIV/AIDS seems to have
different phases and different
epidemiologies,
according to different
circumstances;
and that in the industrial West
it seems to be a disease,
more of marginal groups,
at least at the moment.
It used not to be.
When it was first introduced
into the United States,
for example,
it wasn't an example of
socioeconomic marginality;
but rather people who,
because of sexual orientation,
or through blood supplies and
so forth.
But it would seem that if you
were dealing at a global level
now,
with AIDS in Africa for
example, poverty does seem to be
a very important factor in the
disease.
Would you not agree with that?
Student:  Yes definitely.
I think in countries where
there is more wealth,
it's seen more as a chronic
disease.
So, definitely.
Prof: Okay.
Great, well thank you.
So, we could even
talk--divide--break some of the
diseases down into different
periods in their transmission.
And you wanted to add something?
Student:  That was the
comment.
Prof: Oh,
that was what you wanted to
add.
Okay.
Well, there's another.
Thank you.
Student:  I was just
going to say that tuberculosis
should be added to the list--
probably more on the end of
influenza--
simply because they kind of
regarded it as disease of the
rich for some time--
and a disease of genius,
I think it was--
because of the people that it
affected.
Prof: Okay.
So, there's the thought that
maybe tuberculosis ought to be
added to the influenza end of
the spectrum,
in that it seemed to be,
looking back on the
nineteenth-century experience of
the disease,
it was even described as a
disease of beauty,
of genius.
And clearly we can make a long
list of high society
people--celebrities,
artists, kings and queens--who
were afflicted by tuberculosis.
And I think that if you were
dealing with the nineteenth
century, that would be a
splendid argument to make,
and I agree with you entirely.
I'm just wondering though if we
come forward,
fast forward in time to today,
then I think we have to say
that the epidemiology of
tuberculosis today is different,
and that it thrives on
preexisting conditions,
on overcrowding.
So, I think the time period can
also be important.
Tuberculosis has retreated to
areas of poverty,
I would argue,
now.
Would you agree with that?
Student:  Yes.
I was going to say that what
you were just talking about;
how, like, different time eras
actually can delineate whether
or not it is a disease of
poverty or not,
just by the people that it
affects,
the effect it has on the
society at the present moment.
Prof: Okay,
thanks very much.
Yes.
I think we're seeing that
describing diseases as diseases
of poverty is really a complex
and also debatable position,
and it depends on what
diseases, where,
when and so forth.
It's actually--one needs to
break down what poverty is,
and one needs to have a
spectrum of diseases.
But I think we're dealing with
it much more effectively.
And I think one of the things
we see is that the more
complexity, the more nuance,
the better our answer is
becoming;
also the more interesting.
I think it's rather a bland and
not very convincing answer to
say simply all diseases are
diseases of poverty,
and I think we now see that
actually the situation is much
more complex than that;
that poverty's an important
factor but it doesn't simply--we
can't reduce our course to that
one variable.
Okay.
In the meanwhile have you
thought of other questions that
we ought to be dealing with in
our course?
Or shall I put it another way;
are there major themes in our
course?
What--could we make maybe a
shortlist of themes that you
should be thinking about as you
do your revision?
What are the major themes that
we've been dealing with this
semester?
Disease and poverty is an
example.
Are there other themes?
Go for it.
Student:  I guess
another theme has been the magic
bullet theory of combating
disease,
and the idea that any epidemic
disease can be solved basically
by coming up with some sort of
scientific cure that--
so just, I guess,
quinine in the case of malaria.
I guess in the case of--or
quinine and then DDT in the case
of malaria.
And I guess that theme has been
one that has sort of been
underlying what has been sort of
this triumphal age of American
medicine,
and one that I think,
at least in emerging and
remerging disease,
is something that we're
increasingly viewing as not
exactly the most effective way
of dealing with epidemic
disease.
Prof: Okay,
thanks very much.
Yes, one of the--another theme
of our course has been the
tendency to think of finding a
magic bullet to each infectious
disease.
And you were just starting to
do what I think would then be
really important if that were a
question on the final,
which is to look at what is the
history of magic bullets,
and have they actually
delivered on the promise
associated with them?
And examples that you
gave--let's see,
quinine with regard to malaria,
or later on DDT with regard to
malaria,
and has that--would that
be--would malaria be a good
example of a disease that's been
highly responsive to magic
bullets?
You're shaking your head.
Do you want to add to your
headshake?
Student:  No.
Because there were side effects
to these mass treatments,
and it wasn't a
one-size-fits-all sort of
response to malaria.
And there were other social
factors that weren't considered.
And people were thinking at
that time that if we applied DDT
for a certain amount of time,
then malaria would be
eradicated forever.
But that certainly wasn't the
case, and conditions could
change and the disease came
back.
I think it was the case near
Italy where they built the dam,
and then during the war the dam
was broken,
and then later the disease came
back,
during the war.
So, these measures aren't
permanent, as they thought they
initially were.
In that sense this magic bullet
can't be the permanent final
answer.
Prof: Okay.
So, we have a problem with
malaria.
There was this great euphoria
of thinking that a magic bullet
could be found,
and quinine and DDT were
examples, but they ended up not
actually delivering on the
promise.
Chloroquine would be yet
another example of a magic
bullet, for dealing with
malaria.
So, I would agree entirely.
Malaria would be a wonderful
example of enormous expectations
of a magic bullet as a solution,
and yet we see that,
in fact, the biology of the
disease is much more complicated
than being dealt with in that
way,
and we've seen resistance being
developed by mosquitoes and by
plasmodia.
And, so, the promise of the
magic bullets,
with malaria,
turned out to be a tool.
And they're useful but they
haven't rid the world at all of
the disease.
And there was--you wanted also
to say something.
Student:  Yes.
And I think to go along with
that, there's another reason why
magic bullets can't entirely
work--
and that's another theme of the
class--
which is the idea of disease as
a social construction.
And the fact is that even if a
magic bullet can have a great
effect on the biology,
or the symptomatology,
of a disease--
I think Barnes is the author
who really went into the idea
that in order to really attack a
disease,
it goes into the substratum of
society and to our ideas about
disease and what we place,
the stigma that we place on
them.
Prof: Okay.
So we can't just think in terms
of magic bullets.
We also have to think about the
ideas in people's heads.
How do they understand the
disease?
What's the social construction?
And you gave the example of
tuberculosis as a good example.
Okay, I would entirely agree
with that too.
I'm wondering if there are
other examples of magic bullets
that have either delivered on
the promise, or have failed to
deliver on the promise.
We've talked about malaria:
quinine, DDT,
chloroquine.
What about other--have magic
bullets played a role in our
course with other diseases?
Yes, go for it.
Student:  The original
magic bullet was with syphilis
though--right?--with penicillin.
And I think that was a pretty
good example.
I mean, and Brandt's point,
in No Magic Bullet,
is that it didn't really--I
mean, it helped,
but it didn't really slow the
incidence.
Like it would sort of go in
crests and waves,
where there were people who
were soldiers in the army and
they would get prostitutes,
and then it kind of didn't
really matter whether there was
a cure for syphilis or not,
because like they just wouldn't
have had access to it;
like even if they contracted
the disease.
So, education and other
programs like that are just as
important as drugs,
when it comes to preventing
something like an STD.
Prof: Okay.
The history of syphilis would
be another good case study for
whether magic bullets are the
way to eradicate or control
major diseases.
And you used the example of
penicillin, which is a good one.
But I think we've had,
with syphilis,
even further back,
other things that at the time
were thought of as magic
bullets;
mercury before that,
and salversan,
would be other earlier ideas
considered magic bullets that
also didn't eliminate the
disease.
The diseases tend to be much
more complicated than to be
simply amenable to a magic
bullet solution.
So, syphilis is another
example, along with malaria.
Right?
Are there other examples?
Yes?
Student:  One instance
where this magic bullet idea did
seem to work was in the case of
smallpox,
where a vaccine was developed
and given to all the population,
such that the disease no longer
had a host of humans,
a reserve full of hosts to
infect, and the disease
eventually was eradicated.
And I think that's one example
where this magic bullet was
effective.
But it was a very special case,
in the case of smallpox,
because the smallpox vaccine
was very effective.
And I think we talked about how
it's very much disease-specific.
And smallpox seems to be an
exception rather than the rule,
in terms of how magic bullets
can work.
Prof: Okay, thanks.
So, we need to be careful,
even in our skepticism about
magic bullets,
that there may be cases when
they can actually work;
and a good example being
smallpox in which the vaccine
has actually eradicated
naturally-occurring smallpox
from the world.
There are examples.
But then one has--you were also
saying what lessons should be
drawn from smallpox?
And you were saying perhaps one
of the lessons though is that
smallpox is atypical.
It had certain specific
features about it that made it
particularly vulnerable to
attack by vaccination.
But we can't throw out then the
hope for finding tools that will
actually eradicate diseases,
and smallpox is an example of
something that really did work.
Yes, okay.
Any other examples that ought
to be thrown into our mix?
How about TB?
And streptomycin would be
another example,
I would think,
of something that seemed,
after World War II,
that it would be possible to
close all of the sanitaria;
and that largely happened,
and the outlook seemed to be
that TB would be eliminated by
this magic bullet.
But we see again the problem of
drug resistance,
and we're living now in a world
in which there's multiple
drug-resistant tuberculosis.
And, so, once again we have an
example of a disease that's been
much more recalcitrant,
because we see the--I guess
that Darwin was right--
the influence of evolution and
its impact on the microbes
surrounding us.
Okay.
Is there another major theme of
our course?
We've seen magic bullets,
we've seen poverty,
we've seen modes of
transmission as major impacts on
disease.
We've talked about mortality,
morbidity,
and whether--how you--what are
the--
symptomatology--what are the
factors that contribute to the
impact of a disease on society?
We have just a few more minutes.
So, I'm wondering if we have at
least one more candidate for a
major theme of our course.
Yes?
Student:  The evolution
of public health strategies in
response to epidemic disease.
Prof: Okay.
That's not fair.
You read my mind.
I was thinking of exactly that.
And I did want to say that it
would be unfortunate if you went
to the final exam in our course
without also thinking about
public health as a major theme
that we've covered in our
course.
And let me just--could we make
a list now?
We don't have time for
discussion, but what are some of
the major forms of public health
strategy that we have talked
about?
Okay.
Student:  Quarantine.
Prof: Okay.
Quarantine.
And maybe we might enlarge that
by saying--could we talk about
plague strategies of defense
against infectious disease?
Meaning quarantines,
sanitary cordons,
possibly lazarettos and pest
houses, all the rest that go
with that.
Yes, that's a recurrent--and
that's not only against plague,
but plague strategies were
rolled out again and again in
our course.
We've seen them applied,
not very helpfully,
against cholera.
We've seen them also--plague
strategies--being applied
against HIV/AIDS,
in the early days.
Okay, so that's one style of
public health.
What other measures of public
health have we seen?
Yes?
Student:  We've seen
vaccinations,
concealment,
educational campaigns.
Prof: Okay,
you've got a list here,
that's three more styles.
We've seen vaccination as--you
remember going back to Edward
Jenner and--that was a long time
ago, I admit,
but that's important to
remember.
There were--we've also seen
concealment, and we saw
concealment in the case of SARS.
It occurred in the case of
cholera, in our course.
We've talked about education
and its impact on public health.
Are there other styles of
public health that we've come
across?
Yes?
Student:  Miasmatism,
for a time.
Prof: Okay.
We've seen public health based
on miasmatism,
and with the filth theory of
disease.
And therefore sanitation,
introducing urban cleanups,
sewer systems;
even the rebuilding of cites,
as we saw under Haussmann in
France.
And we saw that in the
rebuilding of Naples also.
So, those are additional styles
of public health.
Anything else anyone wants to
throw in?
Or is there maybe another final
sort of question or theme of the
course?
We've just briefly suggested
public health,
and a few dimensions.
There are others,
and I hope that you'll dig them
out also.
Is there any final question
anyone wants to bring up?
Yes?
Student:  I think maybe
we missed the intrusion of the
modern state played a role in
it;
dispensaries and registries of
victims of disease.
Prof: Okay, okay.
We could discuss also the way
in which the modern state has
played a role in the control of
disease,
and that we can see that in
tuberculosis,
through dispensaries, sanatoria.
We can see that also playing a
role through malaria,
and the same sort of idea of
dispensaries again.
And there are other diseases as
well.
The state playing a role in
education, the state playing a
role in the plague measures
also.
So, I think we can see the role
of the state as a major player,
a central player,
in public health could indeed
be an important theme of our
class.
But having said that,
another theme is stopping when
we've run out of time.
And, so, I'll do that,
and wish you good luck on the
final.
And thank you this morning for
helping us put our heads
together.
And I liked your comments.
Thanks very much.
**